hi there steve kaufman here today to
talk about languages again
and today i want to talk about words
all right now remember if you enjoy
these videos where i talk about language
learning please subscribe
if you feel so inclined give me a like
now when we started link
this is 14 15 years ago
based on my experience and at that time
i had learned nine languages
i said that the the single most
important measurement of your
capability in a language
was the number of words you know
um
capability now you may have a a large
passive vocabulary and if you don't have
an opportunity to speak you may not
speak well
but if you start speaking and speak a
lot and don't worry about how you speak
if you have a lot of words you will
eventually speak well so that
getting lots of words in you initially
passively and then some of those will
become active vocabulary
that's the key how many words do you
know now when we set up link we wanted
to make sure that we measured that and
we do measure it we measure it simply on
the basis that
if you read a text on our system and you
don't look up the word we assume you
know it if you come across it again and
you now feel you don't know it or you
don't know it in this context you can
look it up again and the statistics
adjust but we have a statistic on the
number of words you know
bear in mind that
knowing a word doesn't mean that you
know the full range of meaning of that
word
these are only things that you acquire
eventually through lots of exposure
we also measure the number of words
that you look up we call that creating
links and when you create a link in
other words you see a word you don't
know
you save it it's initially highlighted
in blue you save it
it becomes yellow and then it goes
through
different stages
status so to speak and status 1 status 2
status three status four and we do
define that somehow let me just have a
look here quickly
so that you know one is new
two is can't remember
three is
not sure but you're getting closer and
four is learned so arbitrarily we have
these four
statuses and the yellow gets
progressively lighter
and typically what i do is i adjust
these statuses manually sometimes
making the yellow lighter like i feel i
know this then i'm not so sure i know it
and i move it back
but the status is also adjusted
automatically when you go through
flashcards
a process that i'm not totally familiar
with and which may in fact change going
forward but the point is that
i have let's say in arabic or in any of
my languages like say in arabic going
from memory i think i have supposedly 10
000 known words
the known word can either be a word that
i moved to known that i learned or which
i chose not to say because it was
similar to some other word and i felt
that i understood the meaning
so i have about
10 000
known words
but i have like
far more
uh words that i have
saved at some point links that i have
created
uh in fact i i remember more clearly the
situation in farsi in persian where i
have 3 500 known words but i have like
12 000 saved links
12 000.
what was interesting to me
i went into our vocab section
and we have filters there
so i can filter so that i can see just
the status one words the new words
just
the status two which i kinda
i know that i've seen them before but i
can't remember
three which is i'm not really sure but
i'm kind of half sure of the meaning and
then four is i've learned it
so
you know what i found when i went
through in farsi and in other languages
that the overwhelming majority of the
words
that i had saved that i had encountered
and created this links the overwhelming
majority were in status one like 80 or
more of the words that i had looked up
were still status one i hadn't moved
them to status 2.
what i also found was
that if i went through
flashcards or even going down a list
all of my status three words i knew a
lot of those words
so that i had a good chance like it sort
of was meaningful to do flashcards
because i had a good chance of getting
it whereas if i go to my status one
words in farsi or arabic i still don't
know any of those words
now
interesting so then i go to a language
like russian
where
and again our statistics at link they
measure items on the screen so a word
like go going goes they're all different
words so you can argue that that's still
the same word and in a language like
russian where there's so many
declensions and inflections
you know if i say i have 80 000 90 000
words in russian
in fact that's not really
you know separate words totally it's
different forms of often the same word
but that's the only thing we're able to
measure
and so there's nothing scientific about
the measurement of the sort of known
words but it is an indication
of what you're doing of your progress in
the language
so in russian
i also went to our vocabulary section
and i looked up my status one words
new words
and there were lots of there was like 40
000 of them again bear in mind the way
we count is is
to some people suspect to me it's
perfectly meaningful it makes sense
because every form of the word performs
differently has a slightly different you
know function in the sentence and so
forth
forty thousand so i looked at the words
my
new words in russian and i know most of
them
so
the point here is that so how do we
acquire these words
we could go through flash carding but i
find that personally when i flash card
certainly my new words in say persian
and arabic i haven't got a chance of
remembering them and so i find that
frustrating and i don't do it however
let's say in persian
um
recently one of the people that i worked
with in in iran she actually is now in
in nepal but
she got she transcribed this podcast
that sort of a self-help podcast and
we're exploring if we can get that on as
contented link
but you know there's as i bring that
text into link there's a lot of white
space there like i have actually learned
a lot of words i haven't learned them by
flash guarding
um
so and this has been the case in in
these languages where it seems like
you'll never learn the words and then
then somehow these words are converted
into known words simply because you
spent so much time listening and reading
so
if i look at my arabic and persian i say
to myself i got all these words in
status one what can i do about it i'm
not gonna go flash card you know in in
persian 10 000 words most of which i
don't know
uh
i'm not going to go flash card
i'm just going to continue listing and
reading here's an interesting
transcript of a podcast self-help
podcast describing a book called deep
work or something or work deep i don't
remember just getting started into it
how to stay concentrated when you're
doing something
and this is interesting and i'm going to
do it in farsi persian and i'm going to
know most of the words
even though i have a limited vocabulary
because again the whole thing
when we deal with words we're dealing
with this rapid decline in word
frequency so that
i have enough words that i can
understand a lot of these contexts
continue to come across words that i saw
before but don't know when i looked them
up again
continue to encounter new words that i
look up and they become you know new
status one words and they're going to
reside in that status one
bucket for a long long time because they
may not show up again for a while but i
will continue doing interesting things
and gradually as has happened in all the
other languages that i have learned
gradually more and more of the language
more and more of the words
become known through this magical
process not because i deliberately tried
to flash card them but because
i saw them i saw them again i might move
them along manually and we may find a
way of doing this automatically that
after you've seen them more than a few
times it moves up until they become
status three words
and then the status three words you have
a good chance maybe you could flash card
those you might
do quite well on them because the whole
idea to me with flash cards is i don't
want to scratch my brain and get
frustrated on the other hand if i'm
getting
kind of exposure to things that i kind
of
60 70 percent know words phrases that i
sort of know and i see them again this
is all reinforcing and it's not
frustrating
so
uh the other thing too of course to
reinforce this idea that words are so
key
when i don't understand
in reading something it's not because i
don't understand the grammar that there
is a limited an amount of grammar to be
understood even if we can't produce it
correctly we understand that there are
cases in russian and there's an
inflection in
in other languages or subjunctive or
whatever it might be or
you know particles in japanese
but it's not the lack of grammar that
prevents me from understanding it's the
lack of words and the number of words is
enormous compared to the grammar rules
so to me language learning is all about
acquiring words
we can't be in a hurry to acquire the
words there is no shortcut to acquiring
the words
the bulk of the words that you meet
after a certain point are relatively low
frequency and they will stay in this
sort of new category at link and slowly
move up
to where they are ready to be launched
into your known word total some more
quickly than others but that's the
process and i guess that's the
conclusion that i come to
after analyzing my vocabulary statistics
at link
i invite you to do the same if you're on
link use those filters
and see just where your
new words are or where you're sorry
where your safe words are and how many
are
in status one two three and how many you
have learned and so forth and and the
main activity for me still is going to
be continuing to listen and read
plowing forward
and uh converting more blue
totally new words
into
you know status one
put them in the pipeline and eventually
they will move towards
known
okay that's what i wanted to say onwards
i look forward to your feedback